du weißt nicht was wir waren die preise
um aufzustehen 12 leute herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in dem
wir heute die ganze sache ein bisschen
anders machen werden und zwar was ist
mit dir wahrscheinlich schon gelesen
ich muss heute auf diesem stuhl sitzen
bei ansprechend sind leute die ich nicht
hätte es dabei wir haben sowohl marks
als ob wir dabei heute was geht
ich bin leben die beiden sächsischen die
bestände ihre aufgabe ist der
hauptaktionär von diesem staat dazu
bekommen und das alles ohne mich zu
berühren dürfen mich nicht gewöhnen
von der spricht wird müssen sie
natürlich richtung das un komitee das
nachricht ging alter bis heute besteht
das prinzip die müssen nicht von diesem
stuhl runter und zwar ohne mich zu
berühren
und wenn ich aufstehe aber dürfen wir
nicht lassen oder so
diese war schon das einzige grund dazu
bekommen nicht ihnen wird immer daran zu
gehen wo er das tor ehe die aufgabe
nicht mehr zu bekommen macht sich
erstmal fest
die sollen jetzt weg kommt menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend aber das
zählt du ja aber das ist schon brauch
folgend wir schalten nicht gemacht
heute ist direkt ins video begehren
losziehen anzeichen seien die schüler
angehören rund ein jahr nach oben
schrauben
und auch ein
doch erst mit auf denkt
der junge macht den mund auf
viel passiert er wenn du aufstehst und
weiß ich das nicht mehr zu schaffen
diese brauche ich kein fan alter des
videos gab natürlich könnt ihr einfach
ein bisschen nach wir es mal zu spät
aktiv was im stock abbruch ist jetzt
aber ich dachte das ist der zweck machen
prinzessin werden ja aber ich richte
mich gott will dass wir dürfen die
nerven sondern ein bisschen dinge nur
insoweit gemeldet einfach nicht youtube
[Applaus]
super super was ist deine hand passen
das ist eine scheiße wenn das stimmt ist
also ich muß aus heimtücke aber ich muss
nicht mehr in die tüte
aber ich bin den schild auf jeden fall
ja was geht es ab ob ich habe mal in den
kommentaren der schule über heute ist
sozial ich muss mit dem auto zurück
sollte ich mal aufsteht kann sich auf
dem jetzt auch stehen länger warten
jetzt auf das größte neben gerichts die
kommen doch sei der gute kamerad noch
blockieren unternehmen bruder haben und
sagt martina jetzt vielleicht nicht
mitwirken ok alter stoff schon fachleute
nein die sache ist ich habe mich heute
morgen passiert wir haben in die lippe
machen was ihr oder citroen noch
selbstbewusst was jetzt diese stäbchen
ja haben wir nicht gelernt und sie euch
rektal 1
[Musik]
das mache ich wirklich nicht sogar zwei
kranke stolpert er nicht wirklich sauer
sorry sorry dass ich wohl nicht bis zum
weg machen kann es hat viel spaß beim 3
2-sieg halt bot
das ist gleich zwei nicht für mich aus
das einfach aufstehen bestätigt auch
besteht hier nichts auf dem spiel
aber erst richtig los ich würde das
gebäude ein fenster auf stiegen ein
sprecher dies sei nicht nur ein fucking
ich halte ja den stäbchen festen liegen
die anderen in allen körperlichen habe
oder erwarte gewonnen
ich habe noch nie eine speicherkarte der
hosentasche auch ganz wichtig eigentlich
sind doch in einer brühe aus zuletzt
hatte google for nature online was ihr
wissen würzen
wir dürfen uns nicht einfach
er wollte die welt sehen gibt das ist
genau genau was es so lieber mensch der
ist aber so ein sadist da sehr viel spaß
der dreier hätte kein schwarz gehalten
ist wirklich viel spaß gleich um den
pfosten zu setzen
ja eindeutig habe seit drei tagen neues
aufpassen müssen vielleicht und ja da
kann ich dir
[Applaus]
[Musik]
machst du das machst du dich fühlst dich
mal an die opfer
hallo
das ist schon mal überlegt
hinzu kommen keine zuschauer sünder hand
werden gesteht sie nicht auch weiterhin
gut gefüllt habe ja auch die städte
[Musik]
wir fühlen uns kaputt ist das egal
[Applaus]
danke dafür den vorschlag stimmen zu
konkurrieren
was ist dass der abschnitt ist irgendwo
ios ist verklebt denkbar
aha das ist dass das ist okay das ist
mit dem verloren hatte an der bart ist
ab juli täglich bekommen das aber so was
ja klar ich bin den leuten schild macht
macht es uns gut beraten
das feuerzeug islamischer staat werden
also du weißt nie was wir erwartet 30
uhr aufzustehen
und ich bin auch erst geschafft platz
geschafft
die wissenschaft nicht wieder
aufzustehen wie sehe ich keine auskunft
ob auf die check point concepts machen
ja immer was los ist auch dann bekommt
eine zukunft hat spaß man wachstum geben
sind im stall verlinkt auch das video
von millimeter was mich auf die idee
gebracht hat ist auch eine abschreibung
von linken abdecken wohl heute
selbstständig gibt auch eben hier den
hinweis
wenn ihr dann doch mal lust habe was
mich wundern sollte mich war ohne mehl
zitronen und sie war zu sehen könnt ihr
hier nochmal folge was das geht ab
checken dabei der folge macht denn der
alte leute auf 90 jährigen und junge
leute auf alte sachen die so stark mit
ihm verdanke ich vergaben schütz